[Music]
all right yeah good afternoon everyone
uh thanks for joining
uh today we're gonna yeah damian and i
are gonna talk about
uh building uh native solutions um
you know using some of the technologies
like art studio and plumber but
in the context of uh of pharma
and and what that entails so there's
some things that i really like to share
um uh really quickly uh my name is amin
okar
i work at estella's pharma and my
colleague
damian who's the vp at epsilon data
science
um together we're going to talk about
some of the things that
you know as much as possible as much as
we can share that we have worked
at estela's um so quickly i just want to
get
out you know some of the legal
disclaimer that
we're allowed we're supposed to uh you
know share with you
um but so before i i kind of dive deep
into um um you know
what native solutions look like um and
what are the some of the technology
behind it
uh it is it is important to understand
uh the landscape that we operate in
within pharma and what that means so i
really wanted to share
some of the business context around
what the drivers are of the industry so
if we kind of look at
the pharma industry they're you know
some of the key drivers that could be
legal
uh innovation r d some of them are
political
and social but when you d when you dive
deep from
the pharma industry uh within one
particular company and one critical
brand
uh you would also see that there you
know you know
quite a few number of drivers such as
cost prevalence of disease
supply side factors but one of the key
ones that
we want to focus on is the customer and
the customer in pharma
are usually three they're the physicians
or
and then the pair or the patients so
uh i work on the commercial side so
while there are many factors that you
know influence these three
aspects or customers what we want to
focus on
is the physician which is the healthcare
provider so there are multiple factors
that influence a healthcare provider to
make a decision to prescribe
and you know there are some you know
some campaigns
email campaigns or direct to consumer
campaigns or some social programs
where the most effective channel is
always the sales representative
so just to give you an understanding
that a sales representative here in this
case is
a person who physically visits a
physician's office
and details that physician to share
information about
the medicine the drug and its you know
what are the some of the advantages and
how it can
add value and prolong life and save
patients lives
so in this slide you kind of want to
share
the the overall you know landscape of
drivers at each level
and what we're focused on focusing on
which is you know the biggest one is
obviously the industry
but we're trying to be more granular and
we're looking at just the sales rep
what are the different drivers that
ultimately you know
lead the the sales rep to make the
decision that they make when they're
actually on the on the ground on the
field
and i also want to kind of highlight
that
within commercial you know the role of
data science and whatever machine
learning department that you might have
you know we we are working at probably
you know some of the granular levels
where we're
doing forecasting or budget planning and
strategic recommendation
by you know trying to optimize some of
these drivers at the most granular level
so that we can give the business the
most uh actual insight so that they can
then make the best decision but
what i want to highlight is that as
large as you might think your department
might be within you know a pharma
company
you're still making a very small
contribution to the total number piece
of information that they use
to make a strategic decision ideally we
would want to
you know try to move the company towards
more data-driven or analytically driven
company when they're making these
strategic decisions
but you know we're not there yet but
it's important to know that even though
you might have a very large team
you're making a very small contribution
uh to the number and pieces of
information that they're going to use
so therefore it is very important for
your team to get the method of delivery
right and what i mean by that is i'm
trying to
you know have a nice analogy here where
if you're a supplier of a product you
know you spend a lot of time
in processing and packaging creating the
right optimized package
and then you choose a method of delivery
in this case it could be a truck to
deliver that package
to your end customer and when you choose
the right method or delivery in this
case
your product is on time meets the
expectations you have positive feedback
and trust within the supplier
and that results in you know positive
growth however if you choose the wrong
method of delivery
you'll have your product that's either
delayed not on time it doesn't meet the
expectation there's a lack of trust
and ultimately lack of adoption of what
you're trying to sell
similar thing can apply for your data
science group right so within our team
you know we're working and making a lot
of investments in hiring and
you know expanding our analytical and
predictive analytics team
uh focusing a lot on data and etl
processes and automating that end-to-end
data science flow
and then trying to package all these
insights into visualizations
into you know some products could be a
powerpoint slide it could be an excel
chart
and then sharing it with our
stakeholders so that they can
absorb these insights and you know make
some actionable
decisions so when this process and the
method of delivery
is is is chosen as the right way
you would see that your your insights
are delivered the right time they're
actionable and there's high
adoption and there's also a trust and
credibility that's built in between
your group and your stakeholders within
the company
but when you don't have this uh you know
when you don't think about the method of
delivery so you could have
you know some a lot of investments made
into
you know figuring out what the best
model is and you spend a lot of time
iterating over that but you chose or you
did not think about how you deliver
those insights to
a non-technical person in this case it
could be
a sales representative who's supposed to
make decisions based on your insights
that are analytically driven
but they're all lost in in some sort of
report that they can
you know make use of it or make it
actionable and those cases you'll see
that there's a huge
adoption issue and when that happens it
it kind of
questions you know the even the
existence of your department
um to begin with so it is important to
you know
it's actually better to have a mediocre
data science solution
with the right method of delivery then a
more complex one where you know
investments are made in every
you know you know every part of the
process and you kind of miss on the
on how you plan to deliver these
insights and it could it
it could lead to you know lack of
adoption and and also
trust uh whether these analytics even
mean anything for your end customer
so if we try to you know go back and try
to deep dive
into the sales rep here uh and we think
about how we want to optimize the method
of delivery here
so that we can you know activate some of
these analytics and insights that data
science teams produce
one of the approaches here to do that is
a data science team collectively working
together
sending insights to your customer
and then when it approaches your end
user in this case which is the rep which
you're trying to change their behavior
you want to you would want to take that
omnichannel approach where data is
shared across
all of their devices and it's connected
across different devices
it's real time it's synced that you can
send the
predictive insights you know in at the
right time the right frequency
uh it is shared in a small dosage
fashion fashion because you're trying to
you're trying to change their behavior
to take
your recommendation versus their gut
instinct
so having this sort of like closed
channel where all devices are always
available and interconnected
you can solve for that if you have the
right method of delivery so
you have really designed um you know a
set of tools here to really
activate your insights um to to actually
change the decision
for for a sales rep and when that
happens some of the outcomes here we
would notice is you have higher
engagement you have
also you have kind of like reinforced
the strategies that are coming from
headquartered
and finally delivering to the end user
that's on the ground
and we also see this interaction effect
that happens between
one of the drivers which is a sales rep
but now because you have given them all
of these tools that are interconnected
they're also
able to have a way to interact with
other channels so for example if you're
a sales rep you
go to a physician's office and you have
a conversation
you can also absorb some of their
concerns the physicians are having about
patient
you know adherence to the medicine or
some of the problems their own patients
are facing and then you can walk out of
that office and quickly fire off an
email campaign
that gives the physician the right
content that they were concerned about
that's also compliant and
improved so you have this multi-channel
interaction that's happening
because of your approach and how you're
delivering some of these insights
so i think the key thing here is the
business contacts are on pushing the
right information
to the driver in this case which is the
sales rep at the right time
to influence their decision through
small nudges so
you know based on where they are what
they're doing who they're seeing you can
actually nudge them through your phone
or through your
your iwatch and kind of tell them that
here's the next best
action or here's the next best physician
to call and why and provide them with
that context so you've connected
your data science team in-house internal
all the way down to the field
that's that's out there so i think for
us um you know
when we were doing this kind of exercise
you know a native solution
was the right method of delivering
design in this situation to really
activate the insight
so i'm going to pass it over to damien
to kind of cover some of the technical
aspects
thank you so usually the best tools
actually start with a very simple poc
and r and shiny as are just the best
tool to actually
start quickly start early and iterate
fast
and i would like to share with you the
development approach that can lead you
to having an
offline application that is fully native
and
is using the r technology that you are
using to build your models
so usually when you start with a simple
our shiny poc you can iterate very
quickly because of the
shiny capabilities and then at some
points with the feedback of your users
you can create an application that is
ready to go to production
and when you deploy the application and
scale it well this is the right moment
for you to think about
extracting an api and the great part
about it is that
this api can be used not only in the
native application
but you can use it actually anywhere
that you want and this builds a whole
ecosystem of
applications that you can build around
your data i'm going to talk about
the native ipad application that is just
one part of the whole ecosystem
and the great thing about it is that
actually you can reuse the back end the
javascript and the style sheets that you
created
in the first iterations i would like to
focus on three
elements that you need to actually build
a successful application
first one i will talk about scaling then
i will talk about plumber api
and at the end we will talk about the
native application
so let's start with scaling in order to
scale your shiny application and to be
successful in production
you need to follow very simple rules to
have a good
application architecture first of all
try to extract the computations from the
server
as you know r is single threaded and you
you need to make sure that you not
you don't put too much load on the
server while it is running
so you can use the database you can run
the etls you can extract the processes
away from the app and just trigger those
processes and go back to the main thread
also you should make shiny layers thin
shiny is a great middleware
that connects front-end with the
back-end and this is great for
communication
then you should leverage front-end
javascript is a perfect tool it actually
allows you to
create great interactions and sometimes
you don't need even to communicate with
the back ends to do some
amazing actions on the front end
so when you have the right architecture
there is a time to deploy your
application to
our studio connect rcd connect is great
not only because you get the
authentication
but actually it automatically scales all
the processes
behind so it is capable to serve as many
users
as it is possible on one single machine
but of course
sometimes it is not enough to have just
one machine serving all your users
especially if you have an application
that has a thousand users
and you have seen last year that sean
loop was talking about even scaling to
10 000 users
so this is not possible on a very small
one machine
so in order to do that i suggest to have
a very good preparation first
we often use ansible that allows you to
actually automate the process of
installing all the software and
deploying it on our studio connect
so when you have a bare metal or you
just spin up an instance in the cloud
you can just run one single command and
deploy everything provision install all
of the requirements and it just works
so when you have that you can create an
architecture that will allow you to
serve
a lot of users you can scale as much as
you want you just add
additional servers the only thing that
you need to remember
is that you need to have a load balancer
with a sticky session
in front of it now the thing that
excites me the most when it comes to
studio connect is the fact that
not only can you deploy a shiny
application here but actually you are
able to deploy the plumber api
so once you build the whole
infrastructure and you serve a shiny
application
within your team or outside you are now
able to just add
simple plumber api endpoints and they
are going to just work on the same
infrastructure
just next to your shiny application
so let's look at plumber api probably
most of you already know plumber so i'm
just going to
briefly tell you how it works plumber is
a package from
our studio and it allows you to simply
change a function into an http
api so when you look at the example here
you have a function that has arguments a
and b
and it returns just a sum of those two
by adding simple annotations
in the comments you are able to create
an endpoint
that when the whole project is deployed
you can just call for example c url and
pass the data as a post
to get the result so now
when we have the whole infrastructure
and we have the plumber api endpoints
that serve the data to you
this is the probably the hardest part so
the native application
the problem is that we are not able to
build a whole native application with
shiny but as you are advanced shiny
developers
you already probably have worked with
javascript as well
so the good news is that you can
leverage your javascript skills
or the skills within your team to
actually create a native application
using the react native package and
library
so react native is a library that is
created and maintained by facebook
and it actually allows you to create
fully native applications
just using the javascript so let me
quickly tell
you how react works by itself react
creates an
html structure within the web browser
and it is waiting for any events
in in the javascript event loop so
let's say the action is that we want to
change the word world
to react what react does in the
behind the scenes is creating the new
version of the html structure that we
want to apply
it checks what is the difference between
those two
and it applies only the div to the
result so you do not re-render
everything you just
change one simple component within your
application
now what is great is that when you learn
react then
you will be able to use react native
just
just right away because it works exactly
the same way
it has a react it has a javascript event
loop
running on the ipad on iphone on
any android device for example and the
only thing that it does it actually
does exam exactly the same it checks
what has changed and it applies the
change
but it is a real native component so to
show you the final architecture that you
would have in order to have such a
offline solution
is on the left you have the scaled
architecture where you have plumber api
deployed on our studio connect
as well as the shiny application that
you have been using and then to the
right you have
your ipads that are actually running
react native in the background
and are showing the fully native
application that is syncing the data
with your plumber api endpoints
now what is great about this is that
when the device goes offline
it actually still works because there is
a local store that you can save to
and it is up to you to write the code to
make it sync well
with the end points but then whenever
you have people that are traveling for
example and they don't have much
internet
they're not going to see a lot of
intermissions because they can just go
offline
and use the app whenever they want so
that's the technological part of
of building such solution but this is
not the most difficult part
of course making it happen in the
business is actually much more difficult
as probably
all of you know so i'm going to pass it
on to
iman to talk about the rest thanks david
yeah so
just last two slides i know we're almost
out of time but some of the things i
really wanted to share that
you can't really google or find out in a
tutorial
is kind of like how do you implement
such a large-scale application which is
used by hundreds and hundreds of users
on a day-to-day basis uh and it kind of
put it on
out of there on the slide but i think it
is important to make sure that you
establish
some sort of steering committee and you
have uh you know senior leadership kind
of like bought into your idea
and my like in my experience one of the
the best ways
to do it was always create a prototype
by yourself in chinese so
writing a working prototype uh an
application that they can feel and touch
to kind of you know sell your vision
and communicate the message that you're
trying to try to solve for is kind of
key
uh so you can kind of review this stuff
uh
but i will still end with the same thing
that you know you got to choose the
right method of delivery
so that you can really activate some of
your analytics and insights that you're
investing a lot of time
within your data science teams thank you
you